[Musik]
sebastian nie gemacht eis so günstig wie
möglich ohne die vorschriften zu umgehen
denn die lassen ziemlich viel trickserei
zu produktentwicklern sebastian lege
zeigt uns wo bei billig eingespart wird
wir machen nur ein vanilleeis und dafür
nehmen wir natürlich vanille aber nicht
das teure mag das fürs vanilla ice wäre
viel zu teuer
wir holen heute alles aus der schale
vanille schale ins kies und ein riss
geschmack nicht sich noch heraus kochen
es ist so schön weil ich so unser
extrakt ist fertig die schale wird jetzt
noch getrocknet damit wir später kleine
pünktchen unserem analyser und dann
haben wir alles rausgeholt was nicht nur
geht
die getrockneten schalen werden zu
feilen vanille körnchen vermag
statt im bio müll landet die schale im
billigen vanilleeis und jetzt darf drauf
stehen mit echter bongani stimmt ja auch
alle zutaten werden jetzt miteinander
vereint wir fangen natürlich mit der
wichtigsten zutat an die auch am
günstigsten ist unser freund wasser dazu
kommt milchpulver und ein kleiner
tropfen sahne bei eiscreme muss nur zehn
prozent des rechts aus milch stammen den
rest ersetzt günstiges pflanzen zweck
zuckersirup liefert die süße und die
glück serie halten die eiskristalle shen
klein etwas wacker mail um das
abzuwenden
und zu guter letzt der sud der aus
gekochten vanilleschoten für den
geschmack
da wir natürlich immer nicht genügend
vanille geschmack haben
helfen wir mit künstlichen vanille aroma
mit vanillin einfach nach hier haben wir
unsere kleinen getrockneten
vanilleschoten schalen die uns
vorgaukeln dass echtes vanillemark in
unserem vanilla ice ist das ganze darf
sich später premium bourbon vanille
nennen
immerhin ist ja vanille schalow drin der
geschmack stammt aus dem labor vanillin
wird industriellen meist aus resten yapi
produktion gewonnen
unser vanilla ice sie zwar schon
wirklich gut aus aber irgendwas fehlt
diese typisch gelbe farbe die natürlich
bei frischem eis aus aigle kommt nehmen
wir nicht viel zu teuer
das zaubert und sie mehrere die möhren
liefert carotin einen der wichtigsten
farbstoffe der lebensmittelindustrie
sein vorteil carotin darf fast in allen
lebensmitteln als zusatzstoff eingesetzt
werden
außer im vanilleeis verhilft der müll
dann ganz oft auch butter margarine und
käse zu einem schönen kräftigen geld tun
jetzt muss die masse nur noch kurz in
die eismaschine
und da
fertig ist die günstige vanilla eiskrem
aus der industrie küche das hier zu
bauen
es schmeckt wie vanilleeis und hat so
klar klitzekleine schwarze punkte ein
echtes bonbon vanilla ice wasser aroma-
und nur zehn prozent fett aus der milch
warum darf sebastian das noch eiscreme
nennen
die antwort steht in den deutschen
lebensmittel leitsätzen für speiseeis
je nachdem wie finde ich inklusive fed
im eis steckt bekommt es einen anderen
namen und das kann sie mich schnell zu
verwirrungen führen reifte zum sahneeis
stecken mindestens 18 prozent milchfett
aus der saane drin in eiscreme wie
sebastian es hergestellt hat hingegen
nur noch mindestens zehn prozent und
achtung
in krimis muss die industrie mindestens
50 prozent vollmilch und 90 gramm pro
liter verarbeiten wasser gehört hier auf
gar keinen fall rein natürlich geht es
auch viel günstiger wird etwas nur als
eis verkauft muss nicht einmal milch
verarbeitet werden hier reichen billige
pflanzenfette und aromen wie das geht
zeigt euch sebastian wir machen heute
speiseeis mit apple geschmack was wir
dafür überhaupt nicht brauchen sind
natürlich erdbeeren auch keine teure
sahne und keiner merkt dass wir hier
richtig billiges speise als mit apple
geschmack
die industrie setzt auf lange haltbare
zutaten und streckt so weit wie möglich
[Musik]
günstiges eisbach man nur mit viel viel
wasser weil das kunde direkt aus der
leitung und ist super billig außerdem
günstiges magermilchpulver statt
frischer milch
[Musik]
als basis künstliches vanille aroma bis
sie wieder echte vanille ist wahnsinn
ein schuss blick für ihn sorgt dafür
dass die eiskristalle schön klein
bleiben
cremig wird das ganze durch den
zusatzstoff xanthan für den google
schmelz pflanzenfett das ist günstig und
fühlt sich auf der zunge wie sahne an
für die richtige farbe sorgen keine
erdbeeren sondern rote beete pulver
künstliches aroma bringt den
unverwechselbaren erdbeergeschmack 12345
tropfen reichten und zack schmeckt unser
weißer kleister mit rote beete pulver
nach erdbeere aber wird zum viertel topf
werde ich nicht reich fehlt noch die
billigste zutat überhaupt
corell
ordentlich gelungen zu erzeugen brauche
ich richtig umdrehung und für ort nicht
luft habe ich einen kleinen super
propeller sebastian kühl von außen mit
trockenheit
er will seine eismasse soweit aufpusten
wie nur möglich wenn speiseeis wird im
supermarkt in litern verkauft nicht in
kilogramm mehr luft bedeutet mehr
gesehen
es wird richtig gefährlich jetzt kommt
flüssiger stickstoff ins spiel
der es minus 200 grad kalt und sorgt im
eis für express artige kühlung sebastian
schaltet den propeller damit ganz viel
luft in der gefrierenden masse bleibt
[Musik]
die industrie nutzt für den sogenannten
luft aufschlag andere techniken das
ergebnis ist das gleiche
da ist das volumen ausgeschöpft so wenig
eis habe ich so viel gemacht und hier
ist mein speiseeis mit erdbeergeschmack
dessen roter beete farbe und doppelt so
viel volumen beim luft aufschlag gibt es
für die industrie übrigens kein
gesetzliches limit halt luft preis und
trotzdem darf es noch speiseeis genannt
werden
[Musik]
es schmeckt nach erdbeere ist quietschig
roth aus wie erdbeere
das wird nie einer mehr der nicht auf
die verpackung schaut sebastian denn
auch für die geschmacks bezeichnung gibt
es vorschriften wobei für das eis mit
erdbeergeschmack von sebastian gibt es
fast keine der geschmack entsteht hier
ausschließlich oder überwiegend durch
die zugabe von aromen streicht man den
geschmack müssen mindestens zehn prozent
frucht drinstecken bei mindestens 20
prozent fruchtanteil darf man dann auch
endlich erdbeereis sagen habt ihr schon
mal selber gemacht oder kräfte lieber im
supermarkt zu sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniere die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips